if you were waiting to pick up a ps4 for  uncharted 4 then sony has the perfect  gift for you a thief's and is getting  its own console bundle when it launches  in April not bad for Drake's final  adventures the $400 bundle includes a  gray-blue Nathan Drake stamped onto the  ps4 and a matching dual shock controller  the console also bears the words sick  parvis magna the phrase written on  drake's ring and of course a copy of the  game is included pre-order the new  console and you'll get a voucher for a  weapon skin and character outfit in the  game's multiplayer mode you'll also get  some free uncharted points but we don't  know how many just yet if you don't need  a whole ps4 sony will also be selling  just the controller and march for 65  bucks hopefully that'll hold you over  until the games for release on april  26th in the meantime we'll have all the  uncharted updates at gamespot  you